so the other day I played a voicemail on  my podcast from a viewer and I'm not  going to say exactly what the viewer  said because it's quite vulgar and it  might get me kicked off of some of these  platforms you you sit back waiting at  the headlines  that make your side look good in your  own eyes  you know Josephine will suck his nuts  the entire segment that's what you do  but needless to say it turns out that  the viewer was drunk doesn't remember  leaving the voicemail and has since  apologized on my subreddit now I think  that that's great that they came forward  and said I didn't mean it I do think  that it's indicative  of a problem with alcohol and that's a  really sad thing and we don't make fun  of that that's not something we make fun  of we're talking about an illness but I  always respect when people come forward  and say for whatever reason substances  or anything else  I didn't mean what I said  that I can respect